good afternoon what a joy and a
privilege to welcome you all into one
space as you celebrate one another's
vision and we all have this opportunity
to honor your achievements and what
possibility a moment like this creates
for fundamentally today in it in its
purest sense is a celebration of being
part of a creative collective a
community in fact it's about the promise
of collaboration you are here not just
because of your own efforts but the
collective efforts of the hundreds of
people who work tirelessly together to
shape and tell one story stories that
have moved us and pushed us in ways we
did not think possible and here now in a
time marked by great fragmentation noise
and unrest we have the opportunity to
join together as a single community and
shape a coherent narrative a narrative
that gives voice to those without voice
that honors the experiences and the
dreams of not just the few but the many
a narrative that does not propagate
myths but dispels them a narrative that
does not tacitly condoning equity but
rather highlights and nurtures the
truths that lead to greater empathy and
give rise to justice this is why we are
here and now let us take the time to
honor the work you have done and will
continue to do this is our opportunity
to recognize your profound imprint and
it is the Academy's great hope that by
recognizing these works they will be
found by that many more who so need your
stories and now it is my great privilege
to announce each nominee
and invite you to the risers where you
will all gather for the historic class
of 2018 photograph
[Applause]
so everyone if you look over here stage
managers will greet you as you approach
the stage and they will assist you on to
the risers shall we do this let's do
this ladies and gentlemen what a
gorgeous way to begin Spike Lee
Best Picture directing and adapted
screenplay black clansmen
Amy Adams
[Applause]
Actress in a supporting role vice Ruth
Carter
[Music]
costume design for Black Panther
john mayer production design mary
poppins returns dummy she best animated
short film bow
[Applause]
Julie Cohen Best Documentary Feature RBG
[Applause]
Richard II grant actor in a supporting
role can you ever forgive me Eiling lee
sound editing and sound mixing first man
[Applause]
Hannah
beekler production design black panther
[Applause]
Marina de tavira actress in a supporting
role for Roma
[Applause]
Jeremy kleiner Best Picture vice
[Applause]
Sam Elliott's
[Applause]
actor in a supporting role a star is
born florian henckel von donnersmarck
director of germany's nominee for Best
Foreign Language Film never look away
[Applause]
Charly Wachtel adapted screenplay black
plans now
[Applause]
Peters farily Best Picture and Original
Screenplay Green Book
Nicole Paradis Grindle best animated
feature film Incredibles 2
[Applause]
Lynette how old Taylor
best picture a star is born
[Applause]
Frank a Montano sound mixing first man
[Applause]
Matthew Butler visual-effects ready
player one
[Applause]
Regina King
[Applause]
actress and a supporting role if Peel
Street could talk
[Applause]
Kiro kazoo go da de director of Japan's
nominee for Best Foreign Language Film
shoplifters
[Applause]
Terence Blanchard original score' black
Landsman
[Applause]
Kevin Feige
best picture black panther
a queen
Lady Gaga actress in a leading role an
original song sheller from a star is
born
[Applause]
rahmel Ross Best Documentary Feature
kale County this morning this evening
[Applause]
jalisa aparicio actress in a leading
role drama
[Applause]
Bradley Cooper
Best Picture actor in a leading role and
adapted screenplay a star is born
[Applause]
Brad Bird best animated feature film
Incredibles 2
[Applause]
Pamela gold Dahmer makeup and
hairstyling for border
[Applause]
rami malek
actor in a leading role Bohemian
Rhapsody David shirk visual effects
ready player one
[Applause]
Glenn Close
[Applause]
Actress in a leading role the wife ready
Alfonso Cuaron for
Best Picture
cinematography directing original
screenplay and director of Mexico's
nominee for Best Foreign Language Film
Roma
[Applause]
Caleb Deschanel
[Applause]
Cinematography never look away nadine
labaki
[Music]
[Applause]
director of Lebanon's nominee for Best
Foreign Language Film Capernaum
[Applause]
Paul Schrader
[Applause]
original screenplay First Reformed
[Applause]
Christian Bale
actor in a leading role advice
[Applause]
Barry Jenkins
adapted screenplay if Beale Street could
talk
[Applause]
Rachel vice
[Applause]
Actress in a supporting role the
favorite Jurgis lanthum us
[Applause]
Best Picture
and directing the favorite Eric Ross
adapted screenplay
[Music]
a star is born
[Applause]
Lukasz zsa cinematography Cold War
[Applause]
Maria delle qui Alvarado Best live
action short film mother
[Applause]
Steve Bo Decker sound editing and sound
mixing black panther
[Applause]
a haenyeo Caballero production design
Roma
[Applause]
Theo Jones visual effects Christopher
Robin
[Applause]
Brin Mooser Best Documentary Short
subject lifeboat
[Applause]
Hank Corwin film editing vice
[Applause]
J part production design black panther
[Applause]
Tom owes anak sound mixing a star is
born
[Applause]
Tim calves again sound mixing Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
Jonathan chin Best Documentary Short
subject black sheep
[Applause]
shannon dill Best Documentary Feature
free solo
[Applause]
Edie gyne best picture the favorite
[Applause]
jason blum best picture black clansmen
[Applause]
Melissa McCarthy
[Applause]
Actress in a leading role can you ever
forgive me
[Applause]
Clark Spencer best animated feature film
Ralph breaks the Internet
[Applause]
Brian curry Best Picture and Original
Screenplay Green Book
[Applause]
Phil Lord best animated feature film
spider-man into the spider-verse
[Applause]
Sam Rockwell's
[Applause]
actor in a supporting role vice
[Applause]
Betsy West Best Documentary Feature RBG
[Applause]
[Applause]
Rob braid Oh visual effects solo a Star
Wars story
[Applause]
Rob Epstein Best Documentary Short
subject endgame
[Applause]
Pawel public offski directing and
director of poland's nominee for Best
Foreign Language Film cold war
[Applause]
Gabriela Rodriguez Best Picture Drama
Alice Felton production design the
favorite
[Applause]
Nicole khalaf Center adapted screenplay
can you ever forgive me
[Applause]
skip let's say sound editing and sound
mixing Roma
[Applause]
Becky Nieman table best animated short
film bow
[Applause]
Raika the top sheep Best Documentary
Short subject period end of sentence
[Applause]
Jeremy combs Best live action short film
[Applause]
Ian Hunter visual effects first man
[Applause]
Peter Ramsey best animated feature film
spider-man
- the spider-verse
[Music]
[Applause]
Jimmy chin best documentary feature free
solo
[Applause]
Elizabeth chive Vasarely Best
Documentary Feature free solo
[Applause]
bill Gurdurr best picture a star is born
[Applause]
Grady Cofer visual effects ready player
one
[Applause]
[Applause]
Savio Diaz sound editing Roma
[Applause]
Ludvig goat on son Original Score Black
Panther
[Applause]
John Othman film editing Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
David fine best animated short film
animal behavior
[Applause]
mamoru hosoda best animated feature film
me die
[Applause]
guy not teeth Best live action short
film skin
[Music]
[Applause]
Jamie ray Newman Best live action short
film skin
[Applause]
Allison Snowden best animated short film
animal behavior
[Applause]
Fiona crombie production design the
favorite
[Applause]
nina hearthstone sound editing Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
Steve Mauro sound mixing a star is born
[Applause]
dan sudoc visual effects Avengers
infinity war
[Applause]
Jocelin Barnes Best Documentary Feature
kale County this morning
this evening
[Applause]
Jim Burke Best Picture Green Book
[Applause]
Phil Johnston best animated feature film
Ralph breaks the Internet
[Applause]
Tony McNamara original screenplay the
favorite
[Applause]
Benjamin a Burt sound editing black
panther
[Applause]
Bob her Cecchetti best animated feature
film spider-man into the spider-verse
[Applause]
David Rabinowitz adapted screenplay
black clansmen
[Applause]
Marc Shaiman original score and original
song the place where lost things go from
Mary Poppins returns
[Applause]
Maher Sheila Ali
[Applause]
actor in a supporting role Greenville
[Applause]
Jose Antonio Garcia sound mixing Roma
[Applause]
rich more best animated feature film
Ralph breaks the Internet
[Applause]
mark ronson original song shallow from a
star is born
[Applause]
Barry Alexander Brown film editing black
clansmen
[Applause]
Patricia de Hany makeup and hairstyling
vice
[Applause]
Jeff Whitty adapted screenplay can you
ever forgive me
[Applause]
[Music]
DeeDee Gardner Best Picture vice
[Applause]
Craig Hennigan sound mixing Roma
[Applause]
John Walker best animated feature film
Incredibles 2
[Applause]
Diane Warren original song
I'll fight from RBG
[Applause]
Marshall Curie Best Documentary Short
subject a night at the garden
[Applause]
Willem Dafoe
[Music]
[Applause]
actor in a leading role at eternities
gate
Bing Lu Best Documentary Feature minding
the gap
[Applause]
Patrick Tubac visual effects solo a Star
Wars story
[Applause]
Kevin Willmott adapted screenplay black
Klansmen
[Applause]
Eric a doll sound editing a quiet place
[Applause]
Melissa Burton Best Documentary Short
subject period end of sentence
[Applause]
Trevor Jimenez best animated short film
weekends
[Applause]
jurgis maroc sorry DS film editing the
favorite
[Applause]
Nicholas critera gional score if Beale
Street could talk
[Applause]
Talal derchi best documentary feature of
fathers and sons
[Applause]
Jeffrey Friedman Best Documentary Short
subject endgame
[Applause]
Tristan miles visual-effects first man
[Applause]
Ethan van Duren sound editing a quiet
place
[Applause]
Louise Bagnall best animated short film
late afternoon
[Applause]
Peter Devlin sound mixing black panther
[Music]
[Applause]
Evan pays Best Documentary Feature free
solo
[Applause]
John wore Hearst sound editing Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
John Cazale sound mixing Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
dan de Loup visual effects Avengers
infinity war
[Applause]
we'll Fedders adapted screenplay a star
is born
[Applause]
Maryellen benissa Best live action short
film Marguerite
[Applause]
Gordon's sim production design MARY
POPPINS returns
[Applause]
Patrick J Don Vito film editing
greenbook
[Applause]
sky Fitzgerald Best Documentary Short
subject lifeboat
[Applause]
sooo Kim Best Documentary Feature Hale
County this morning this evening
[Applause]
Brandon Proctor sound mixing black
panther
[Applause]
Raymond Mansfield best picture black
Klansmen
[Applause]
Diane Kuan Best Documentary Feature
minding the gap
[Applause]
Mary saw Freese costume design The
Ballad of Buster Scruggs
[Applause]
Shawn McKittrick best picture black
clansmen
[Applause]
Christopher Miller best animated feature
film spider-man into the spider-verse
[Applause]
Viggo Mortenson actor in a leading role
[Music]
Greenberg
[Applause]
Anthony Rosamond Oh original song
shallow from a star is born
[Applause]
Maryanne Farley Best live action short
film Marguerite
[Applause]
maria gonzalez blanco best animated
short film late afternoon
[Applause]
li Magadh a Best Picture the favorite
[Applause]
Rodney Rothman best animated feature
film spider-man into the spider-verse
[Applause]
Michael Ames visual-effects
Christopher Robin
[Applause]
Vincent Lam Best live action short film
detainment
[Applause]
Paul Massey sound mixing Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
Edie Perkins Best Documentary Short
subject black sheep
[Applause]
Bobby Pontius best animated short film
one small step
[Applause]
Cece Dempsey Best Picture the favorite
[Applause]
Maria Gracia Joe John Best live action
short film foes
[Applause]
Kathy Lucas production design first man
[Applause]
Scott Whitman original song the place
where lost things go Mary Poppins
returns
[Applause]
bada bada Enriquez production design
Roma
[Music]
[Applause]
Darren Mahone Best live action short
film detainment
[Applause]
Kelly port visual effects Avengers
infinity war
[Applause]
Dean zupanic sound mixing a star is born
[Applause]
Russell Earl visual-effects
Avengers infinity war
[Music]
[Applause]
Yuichiro Saito best animated feature
film me die
[Applause]
john taylor sound mixing first man
[Applause]
Charles B Wesler best picture Green Book
[Applause]
Andrew chess worth best animated short
film one small step
[Applause]
Mildred ayat room organ sound editing
first man
[Applause]
Kevin Messick Best Picture vice
[Applause]
Jason ruder sound mixing a star is born
[Applause]
Graham King best picture Bohemian
Rhapsody
[Applause]
greg cannom makeup and hairstyling vice
[Applause]
and lastly Adam McKay
[Music]
[Applause]
Best Picture directing and Original
Screenplay vice
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the 91st Academy Awards nominees class
of 2018
[Applause]
and now
[Applause]
to the nominees we are about to take the
historic photo so nominees if you could
please remove your badges and direct
your attention to the red flashing
lights on the ceiling which is where the
camera is locally located now for the
directors they'll be repeating the photo
five times guys so here's the deal you
got to keep smiling
so keep taking a photo keep smiling
say momma say oh my god
mio Dio Oscar we love you now your
official nominees certificates from the
Academy will be given to you as you
depart today congratulations to all of
you again we're so honored to celebrate
you and your gorgeous work we will see
you on February 24th Oscar's Sunday we
thank you for this gorgeous community
you continue to invent and inspire so
many and soon we will have a museum to
fill your stories filled with so many
generations to come we'll be able to
participate in what you offer thank God
your artists and thank you for making
your beautiful films
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]